E aí
[Música]
e quando eu era criança eu adorava
desmontar as coisas né
o like jogar um brinquedo não vai
brincar não vou desmontar
e desmontava e tirar uma bolinha aquela
pecinha depois voltar de novo só faltava
umas peças lógico mas eu queria o quê
que eu fazer isso eu queria entender o
que que tinha por trás daquilo eu não me
contentava com a superfície eu queria
saber que tinha por dentro como aquilo
funcionava
a aliança
E como que esse papo aqui tá funcionando
o wi-fi a não vai with assim assaltar a
rede no mundo
e como funciona esse tal de wi-fi
e como é possível mais um
Esse é um campo eletromagnético página
assim uma teia de energia que cobre o
planeta
bom então ela consegue transitar uma
frequência pensamento uma floss qualquer
coisa por ondas as ondas nada é como
vibram e tem algum lugar
E então quem são os nossos nós somos
geradores de frequências vamos geradores
de energia e frequências positivos de
frequências negativas e de frequências
neutros Talvez um
E ai muito tá pesado não é não só a
terra está doente aí o ser humanos não
sei paga do mundo
É verdade não é o ser humano que apaga
do mundo é a maneira com que o ser
humano está vibrando que está gerando
a energia negativas no campo
eletromagnético olha o tamanho da
responsabilidade quando eu reclamo
alguma coisa lá lá passou não passou
passou isso para para o campo isso vai
chegar um lugar então
e onde eu quero chegar se nós somos
dotados de uma essência na qual
nós queremos preservar a espécie humana
e tu faz parte do nosso DNA você pode
estar super ocupado indo levar Sei lá só
esposa no pare de repente uma velhinha
tomba do seu lado em algum momento você
vai
eu queria ajudar ela ou vai pensar em
ajudar ela porque porque somos
conectadas somos uma espécie conectada
ninguém aprendendo sozinho é preciso
compartilhar é pesquisa interagir somos
um organismo vivo
os indivíduos formando um organismo vivo
e não história da humanidade 150 anos
atrás não tinha luz elétrica Lampião
de repente duas gerações três Quem sabe
depois nanotecnologia a idade virtual
computador quântico maioria da população
mundial com o celular na mão smartphone
podendo fazer todo tipo de informação a
gente usa esse para quê
o outro isso que almoço energias
negativas ao ponto de 350 milhões de
pessoas estar em depressão a cada 40
segundos uma pessoa e tem roupa para
Filho 800 mil pessoas interrompem a
própria vida por ano
nós estamos conectados estamos na era o
maior avanço tecnológico da história da
humanidade
e esses números existem não faz sentido
vamos postar mais porque
é porque estamos conectados e nos
sentimos sozinhos porque não estamos
conectados da maneira certa
e eu não tô aqui tá aqui de cá nada mas
acredito que existem vícios
eu disse que leva um ser humano a fuga
na distração entre eles
as redes sociais da comprovada
cientificamente rede social em exagero
no seu quanto que é um exagero mas
talvez pra mim meia hora podia um
exagero pergunta muitas outras coisas
meia hora todos os tipos gera um quadro
de ansiedade absurdo jogos eletrônicos e
Sião colocam estados emocionais ativos o
tempo inteiro ansiedade
e seriados você
o melhor no próximo capítulo aquilo que
gera uma cidade deixa eu te fazer feliz
quer fazer as coisas correndo do seu dia
para chegar a hora de ver a próximo
capítulo de algo que
Ah tá realmente colaborando com a
espécie humana tá colaborando e melhorar
esses números então assim que esse
campeonato magnético ele é o que vai
digitar o nosso futuro que a gente vibra
agora o que a gente vai colher depois
universo esse sistema ele só fala assim
não tem como escapar disso é uma fórmula
bom então se ele só fala assim o que que
a gente vai vibrar para ele é importante
saber
a Madre Teresa a considerado o mate né
da Bondade da plenitude do altruísmo ela
falava assim olha se você se vocês me
chamarem não me chamem quando vocês
fizerem alguma passeata contra alguma
coisa mas quando for favor eu posso ir
ela entendia que o campo ele propaga
energia que você envia para ele se a
gente quer mudar essa frequência do
planeta não adianta a gente reclamar uma
de espalhar a notícia sabia que a gente
trazer números não adianta a gente ir
para a Rua Se juntarem Gritar nas
janelas não adianta Só que hora só que
hora a energia e aí eu troco né se na
sua falta sim troco doenças depressão
quedas econômicas tudo energia tudo é
partícula em movimento não tem muito
segredo
e o que que faz para mudar a gente aqui
para que a sofrer ou para viver uma vida
plena vai ter crescimento para se ajudar
estamos todos conectados são bilhões de
celulares no bolso de cada um
e talvez esteja faltando uma ferramenta
ele abusa amigos estamos aí varando
noites não com muito gás muita alegria
para tentar criar uma ferramenta em rede
que seja capaz das pessoas se ajudarem
que seja capaz de criar Campos de
energia positivos para tentar melhorar a
situação porque eu não estou feliz com
esse brinquedo eu quero entender que
está por trás e que que eu posso fazer e
quando eu tiver saúde para poder
colaborar com espécie humana eu queria
trazer essa reflexão aqui nessa
oportunidade que eu posso fazer para
colaborar com a espécie humana que que
eu posso fazer dentro de mim para emitir
para enviar vibrações frequências mais
benéficas para o campo
o que rege nesse planeta que tem que
fazer é preciso respirar eu preciso
meditar eu preciso conversar eu preciso
não vamos cair pra distração chega tem
que passa a vida passa as oportunidades
passam
o meu sonho é Av alm funcionando entre
as pessoas tecnologica mente que você
possa conversar uma pessoa com a outra
de uma maneira inédita que você possa
passar uma energia positiva que alguém
isso é possível é possível fica o
convite aqui para gente fazer parte
desse movimento a gente fazer parte
dessa rede e buscar a tecnologias de
buscar maneiras de vibrar melhor a
evolução tá na Palma das nossas mãos
e vai ser mais simples do que a gente
imagina
e eficaz graças a todos vocês